welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of the new
trailer for The Flash coming June 16th
the DC crossover event where things are
gonna get nuts I'm gonna break down this
trailer frame by frame for all the
Easter eggs and details that you might
have missed let's get started I lost my
parents
that pain
[Music]
made me who I am the trailer opens with
the two Barry Allen's walking up to
Wayne Manor now this is meant to evoke
the house from the 1989 Tim Burton
Batman in the 1992 Batman Returns with
Michael Keaton as Bruce Wayne I just
analyzed the 1989 Batman for the Deep
dive Channel specifically to catch
myself up for this movie and I highly
recommend you watch that analysis
because we wouldn't have any of these
superhero films without all the things
that Michael Keaton Batman did so well
now quick reminder that this movie is
adapting the 2011 Flashpoint event in
which Barry Allen wakes up to find
himself in an altered Darkest Timeline
in which he has no powers and Batman is
a violent Thomas Wayne bothered to Bruce
Wayne and Barry thinks that this
timeline was altered by his Nemesis
reverse flash eobarthan but later
realizes it was really Barry's own doing
in his attempt to go back in time to
prevent his mother from being killed by
reverse flash that caused all of this
this film will adapt this by instead
starting with that choice but rather
than Barry warping into a new timeline
and just assuming what his body would be
in that timeline movie berries speed
force enabled time travel has brought
him into the side Universe where he can
meet his multiversal variant as a body
this is a timeline where his mother Nora
did not die and thus the timeline were
buried never acquired powers and it
seems like Batman is the Tim Burton era
Michael Keaton a universe that was
technically Earth 89 in the DC
Multiverse but this foggy estate with
its towers and parapets is the same type
of English country house as the nebworth
house that was used as Wade Manor in
1989 Batman but this is actually a
different house this is the burglary
house in Stanford Lincolnshire in
England it's not exactly the same house
then again the Wayne Manor exterior did
change between 1989 and the 1992 Batman
Returns it's never really the same
outside design I just love that it is
foggy and Gothic here because every
other shot we see of Wayne Manor it's so
bright and so sunny and I like my Batman
draped in fog we see Bruce Wayne's
bruised fingers bruisy Bruce he's
touched a photograph of him with his
parents Thomas and Martha and these
bruises show how this Batman is still
dancing the Devil with a pale Moonlight
even at an older age we see his empty
workstation it's Gathering dust and
cobwebs and it looks similar to the way
it did in the Burton era films but he
has definitely upgraded his screens to a
more high-tech setup one screen showing
the curved body of the Batmobile up top
the bat wing and to the right his latest
bat suit on the left side looks like
some older audio equipment it's not
exactly this but it is something that
looks like that goofy CD player in
Batman Returns where Bruce DJ the CD to
play back Penguins audio to embarrass
him during his political speech I would
just love who got a reference to that
okay on to the next clip
spent a lifetime trying to right the
wrongs of the path
as if fighting crime would bring my
parents back
you actually did it the Batwing lowers
from the stalactites in the bat cave
hanging the way a bat does and it's
facing a waterfall now I don't remember
the Earth 89 bat cave having a waterfall
like the Nolan vs Batcave did and Batman
Begins Dark Knight and Dark Knight Rises
but again this isn't quite the Earth 89
Universe It's Just Another Universe in
which Batman is Michael Keaton we see a
wider shot of Bruce opening this hidden
door of the bookcase leading to the suit
room before we get to that it looks like
the photo of him with his parents was
the key that unlocked it and above that
there is a photo of someone wearing
armor remember Bruce in the 1989 Batman
film did collect suits of armor in his
mansion and the need at the bottom there
is a black and white photo of an older
generation of the family but into this
chamber it contains seven bat suits from
the left it's a suit with gun holsters
maybe the year one or year two Keaton
Batman who would take lives back in the
day in the comics Batman would just kind
of run around with gun shooting people
then next to that a blue and gray suit
with the 1989 emblem the one with the
feet at the bottom of the silhouette
also notice it has more of a furrowed
brow I love that he's got a blue and
gray suit just one little way that this
Batman and the Ben Affleck Batman in
this movie are having some parallel
facts but then third from the left that
is the 1989 Batman suit the Cape is
draped over the shoulders and its chest
emblem is damaged as that emblem was at
the end of that movie you'll notice this
cow as opposed to the one next to it has
more angular eyebrows that match Michael
Keaton's face exactly which is something
very very important to why that Batman
was so successful and I dove into that
in the Deep dive now to the right of
that in the back the 1992 Batman Returns
suit you'll notice that has the updated
chest emblem even though it was the logo
and all the marketing it was not the one
he actually had on the suit in the 1989
film that wasn't until the 1992 film but
then to the right of that looks like a
scuba bat suit and then on the far right
looks like a desert terrain bat suit
with goggles like the ones half-like
Batman war in the nightmare sequence for
Batman v Superman and in the Snyder cut
but front and center is the Keaton bat
suit of this movie it's a refined design
incorporating the best elements of all
the past iterations of the Keaton era
angular eyebrows and sharp nose on the
cowl the simpler chest emblem the cape
pushed to the sides of the shoulders
leaving the arms Freer for combat
because in that last trailer when they
break free cars or L there's this
awesome moment where she rushes into
Bonk a Russian soldier to hell that
Batman was taken a swing and about to
punch him in the face so this Batman
does not pull his punches I'm super
excited to see some action from him and
you'll notice that this utility belt
isn't yellow but more of a darker
practical one that's a utility belt
actually built for utility now Bruce
says that he fought crime to try to
bring his parents back but that Barry
actually pulled it off referring to
Barry's success and timeline hopping in
a reality where his parents are back but
that's not exactly his mom is it
interesting how Bruce has his hair cut
short in this shot before he seemed to
be like a Howard Hughes style shut it
with overgrown shaggy hair reminded me
of my favorite joke in the Simpsons
we're too late I shouldn't have stopped
for that haircut all right let's move on
I can't imagine what you've been through
I love you monkey you lost both parents
in one day
okay I think we're hearing the voice of
Iris West and she's reminding Barry of
how he lost both of his parents his
mother when she was murdered and his
father Henry now played by Ron
Livingston replacing Billy crudup from
Justice League Henry was framed for
Nora's murder and imprisoned we're kind
of seeing some dual memories here one
Barry and a yellow shirt reflecting the
happy timeline another in a blue shirt
representing the tragic memory of the
day of Nora's death the yellow shirt
Berry I'm thinking is the berry from the
alternate timeline who is often dressed
in yellow the one who never lost Nora
there is a warnery Easter egg here the
yellow shirt shows the Scooby-Doo
Mystery Incorporated team the early odd
Scooby-Doo movies were new DC head James
Gunn's first franchise films and on
Warner owned HBO we got that Velma show
everyone loves and Scooby-Doo was just
referenced in the recent episode of
succession are you scooby-dooing me here
is that where you went
Hannah Barbera in business school also
in Nora's kitchen we see she composts
because she was such a perfect person
and Henry screams call 9-1-1 and we see
Nora went from looking at Barry to
kissing Henry's neck in her dying
breasts moving on I went back in time to
save my parents
instead
I completely broke the universe
okay I love the shot of young Barry
running out of the house as the sky
rapidly shifts from day to night showing
how Barry's perception of the passage of
time has been affected by the speed
force we see what that looks like when
he runs back in time with fiery Spears
bursting outward and then subsiding
maybe each burst representing him
passing through a new timeline but
you'll notice before we cut to Black the
last one bursts blue this is the
coloring of Barry's Speed force from
this point forward they change it from
yellow to Blue in this movie and that
seems to be an important visual clue
blue might be the color that a speed
force takes in this alternate timeline
and a way to visually distinguish him
from his other variant and yeah Ezra
Miller is doing that same goofy run that
they did in the Snyder cut when Barry
reversed time to save the Justice League
but you know what Snyder's visual
effects in that sequence were pretty
incredible Oscars fan chair moment of
the Year incredible maybe not but you
know it was solid Barry skits to a halt
in front of the battle of metropolis
from the 2019 Man of Steel film in the
prologue of the 2016 Batman v Superman
when zod's World engine was in the
process of terraforming Earth presumably
this would be in a reality without
metahumans like hello so no one is here
to stop Zod and save all these people
there's a weird shot here where one kid
is walking toward the destruction and
behind him there is somebody in a
bizarre suit that is definitely not the
berry we just saw I'm wondering if this
could be alternate Berry in a DIY suit
so that's gonna fall apart immediately
what is he doing in the scene why does
he think this suit will help him I don't
know but he is a dumb idiot so to do
these breakdowns I'm on my Mac
constantly for work and the last thing I
need is a spinning beach ball of death
slowing me down that's why I use clean
my Mac X for me clean my Mac X is a
must-have tool whether my Mac is brand
new or 10 years old the app is made with
every Mac in mind playing my Mac X has a
ton of useful features the most
prominent is smart scan which makes sure
no junk files are keeping my Mac from
running as fast as possible clean my Mac
X also comes with an uninstaller to get
rid of all the stuff apps can leave
behind when you delete the main file I
can also use space lens to quickly and
easily see which files are taking up the
most space on my system the newest
version of clean my iMac X also lets me
easily keep tabs on what's going on with
my Ram CPU external disks and connected
devices using the redesigned menu app
and whenever I'm not sure which of clean
my Mac X's Swiss army knife set of tools
would be best to use next I just use the
built-in assistant to figure out what I
need to do to optimize my Max
performance clean my Mac X is the best
way to get the most out of your computer
to get started click the link in the
description and get a free 7-Day trial
of clean my Mac X today and trust me
after using clear my Mac for free for
seven days you're gonna love it as much
as I do click the link in the
description below to start your free
7-Day trial today let's move on if you
look back and change the past this world
must die
change the future
do you know what the symbol stands for
means hope right
okay Michael Shannon returning in this
movie is General Zod I still can't
believe it we see his Kryptonian armor
his face shielding I think this is the
same desert by the military base where
we saw the kryptonians when they took
Kalel in the 2013 film but again because
Kalel is not here that close to counter
is going to get a lot deadlier then the
shot of Gotham General Hospital
collapsing you can see Barry on that
collapsing sidewalk right in front of it
and Martha Wayne Institute on the side
of the building interestingly there's an
elevated train track on the street in
front of it this recalls the Chicago L
train setting Christopher Nolan used for
Gotham in the Dark Knight a film that
also featured a Gotham Hospital
imploding meanwhile these angel statues
have the dramatic Art Deco style that
Gotham had in the Burton and Schumacher
era it seems like they're using elements
of all different eras of Batman movies
and kind of making a new version of
Gotham and Metropolis with it then on
two Supergirl Kara zorel Superman's
cousin played by Sasha Kaye in this
movie she asks Barry what the symbol
stands for and does not expect to know
the answer but he says hope calling back
that moment with Superman and Lois Lane
in the 2013 film this is really the
symbol of the Kryptonian House of L of
which Cara is also part of but Kara in
this movie seems to be playing the role
of Kal-El in the flashpoint in comics
when callal was Kept in government
custody and starved into this palomy
seated form but is broken free to help
Barry and Thomas now in Man of Steel
Zack Snyder left one of those cryopods
open on the Kryptonian ship and implied
that his plan was for that to belong to
khalil's cousin kyrazorell but notice as
Barry says it means hope right the other
Barry behind him is mouthing something
else entirely he's trying to answer the
question but likely having no idea what
it stands for moving on
I will help you if I thought
you want to get nuts
let's get nuts
okay Kara flies beside the jet then
blast forward supersonic breaking the
sound barrier the way Khalil did in the
2013 film just love how it looks but
then Batman calls back his line to the
Joker from the 1989 film
s
come on let's get nuts it's just kind of
wild how self-aware this Bruce is means
that line wasn't really his catchphrase
that whole moment was really Bruce
angrily calling out the Joker's
performative Insanity as someone
actually going through a mental disorder
but the bats at this moment
interestingly even seem to be playing
along with Bruce's masquerade but I
think what's most interesting about this
shot is that in the Super Bowl trailer
The Ring of lights over the cowled
Batman's head were mostly flickered out
because over the years he doesn't give a
about upkeeping this Batcave but
here in this shot they are all lit and
functioning which might be showing how
this Bruce has gotten this batcade back
online maybe also foreshadowing an
Angelic Halo in the event that this
Batman might die in this movie in the
desert Battlefield the Batwing does a
flyby as Barry Cara and the other Berry
arrive all matching each other's speed
but I like how the more experienced
Barry knows to stay low like a speed
skater whereas Barry on the right leans
back and he wobbles and yeah this other
Berry suit looks ridiculous but that's
because it is a modified bat suit the
1992 era it looks like it's been spray
painted red with the yellow Bolt the
ears of the cowl have been shaving down
to Nubs for wind resistance I suppose
and it's got some knee pads let's move
on I have to undo what I did
hey scars would have
make us who we are I'm about to go back
and fix them
no extra tragedy to find you Batman
flies the two berries in the Batwing to
the snowy mountain region presumably the
base where karazorl is being kept
leading to her breakout that we saw in
the first trailer remember in that
footage she was wearing some prison
guard that had Russian lettering these
words translate to the most dangerous we
see a few photos of the Allen family
including a photo booth strip of
youngberry making monkey faces perhaps
connected to Nora's nickname for him
monkey this looks like it's part of a
sequence where Barry speeds past his
loved ones in this other timeline to
just grab a few milliseconds with them
but notice as soon as the tear leaves
his eye it falls at a slower speed of
gravity than it would because he is
moving faster than speed of gravity
would tug that tear down there's this
mysterious shot of Barry touching the
limp charred hand this could be the
other Berry after you electrifies speed
force Powers into his body in the bat
cave that we see later in the trailer
this also might be connected to when
cars or else lies him up into the
heavens maybe to get defibrillated by a
bolts of lightning it's interesting how
Ben Affleck Bruce Wayne has similar
advice to Barry as what Michael Keaton
Bruce said he says the scars we have
make us who we are we're not meant to go
back and think them don't let your
tragedy Define you so while Michael
Keaton Bruce allowed his tragedy to
Define him Ben Affleck Bruce doesn't
want that for Barry I think that's the
key difference between these Batman
Affleck's Batman had to learn to work
with others in the Justice League
whereas Keaton's lived mostly in
solitude on to the next clip
okay more of this desert battle we see
two Kryptonian ships slamming into each
other notice the tow cables and that
batwing flying overhead looks like
Batman lassoed these into each other
Kara is pissed and sod screaming what
did you do I don't know maybe he killed
Kal-El in this reality she hammers away
at his helmet with a pipe Keaton Bruce
protects Barry from machine gun fire but
notice the impact those shots take on
him this old man cannot do it forever we
see Barry running up the side of a
collapsing building which now realizes
probably that collapsing facade of
Gotham hospital I assume we're going to
see him say a lot of alien patients
moving on no matter what we do
We're not gonna be able to fix this no
fed up like Batman looks great at all
these shots he gets attacked with an RPG
and rolls out of that fireball not sure
how he survives this or how he's even
gliding but looks like from the moment
bat Flex gonna drop out of that jet on
the motorcycle and then from the other
trailer skiing from cables this guy is
not gonna stop moving at any point in
the sequence it's just gonna be like one
continuous drive but here we might be
seeing a wedge point between the berries
our berry says no matter what we do
we're not going to be able to fix this
and the other Barry angrily says no
nobody dies the two of them look like
they're in some orange colored Vortex
it's actually kind of similar to the
bubble that was formed when Barry ran
through the time stream earlier in this
trailer it's possible that their actions
will lead to Deaths of others in other
Barry's family maybe the death of Keaton
Batman and then other Barry will turn
against our berry for the Final Act of
this movie and maybe become a form of
reverse flashed and that's why he's
dressed in yellow throughout this movie
Keaton Batman kneels in defeat in the
desert battle similar to Kara in the
earlier shot behind Batman army soldiers
are in retreat but then there's a quick
shot of another mystery Speedster and
dark armor looks Kryptonian I think this
might be the dark flash that's been
teased in merch and and Zod may have
found a way to neutralize these berries
with a Kryptonian Speedster of his own
he leaps onto keep Batman's bat wing and
punches his back canopy just like the
kryptonians do to those jet pilots in
the 2013 Man of Steel the Batman ejects
he bumps into the side of the jet on the
way out we know this jet will crash due
to its wrecked fuselage in the poster
but as he Glides you can see his cape's
ribbon going rigid to turn the cape into
a practical sail our man is hang gliding
I love it below the ground is marked 36
and C for this military base Landing
Zone onto the last bit
you're strapped to your parachutes and
where's yours
wow
I love it the logos for Keaton Batman
act like Batman Superman emblem and
finally The Flash bolts all layer over
each other because let's be real this is
as much a Batman story as it is a flash
story Batman drops the two berries over
this Mountain Base and as Batman
skydives the Batwing forms the bat
signal and the light of the full moon
recreating Tim Burton's iconic shot from
the 1989 film now this movie is being
billed as the ultimate DC crossover
event look back at the interesting
history of DC Cinema that's probably
gonna include other cameos these
trailers haven't shown us yet maybe a
George Clooney Batman maybe a Christian
Bale Batman probably not falcon or
Batman given Val Kilmer's health
condition maybe Keanu Reeves Constantine
but spoiler warning in case this ends up
being accurate the scooper Troopers out
there are claiming that Nicholas Cage
might appear as Superman fighting a
giant robot spider which would be a
throwback to Kevin Smith's story about
when he was developing Superman lives
with producer John Peters and Peters had
all these insane rules about Superman
including the fact that Superman had to
had to fight a giant robot spider and
then a few years after Kevin Smith left
this project that ended up being the
Final Act of John Peters produced wild
wild Quest if this ends up being the
case it sounds like it'll show up as a
brief sighting during like a Multiverse
Montage for this Desert location is
exactly where you could imagine a giant
robot spider appearing John Peters by
the way that's the nating Hollywood
figure Barbra Streisand's hairdresser
turned brief lover turned into major
Hollywood producer somehow attached to
every Batman and Superman movie for
decades he's actually who Bradley
Cooper's character in licorice pizza is
based on I really need to do a deep dive
on how every character you see in movies
is based on some creepy Hollywood figure
Like Jesse eisberg's weird take on Lex
Luthor his impression of Max Landis hey
a reminder to subscribe to our Deep dive
Channel where we are in the middle of a
re-watch of Guardians of the Galaxy and
you can support me doing these deeper
investigations by grabbing one of these
rocket science teas over at
nerdright.shop follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at avos follow the rockstars
And subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
thank you